I think that's a,
I think that's a
crazy idea.
If you look at,
if you look at the growth of prosperity
in this country,
it's basically continued unabated and
the truth of the matter is that the,
what drives this economy is innovation
and ideas and the fact that a
manufacturing shifts around the world,
even some services shift around the
world doesn't mean that American
businesses is finished.
What is going to be true is that we're
going to see a lot of.
We are seeing already a lot of economic
growth elsewhere in the world and China
and India and Brazil,
uh,
the,
the emerging market countries are
experiencing just extraordinary changes
in economic wellbeing and many American
companies like General Electric or like
Citibank,
see a lot of their future growth as
taking place in those markets.
But the fact that they're,
that they're going to do well only bodes
well for us.
Not a,
not anything else.
So.